die nato hat eine klare haltung einer
der sie von innen kennt ist harald kujat
der ehemalige vorsitzende des nato
militärausschusses
und generalinspekteur
guten abend herr kujat
wie lange kann sich die nato diesen
krieg noch anschauen ohne einzuschreiten
die nato wird bei diesem krieg nicht
einschreiten weil die ukraine kein nato
mitgliedsstaat ist die nadel ist ein
verteidigungsbündnis das heißt sie
verteidigt ihre mitgliedsstaaten aber
keine anderen staaten
welche möglichkeiten hat die nato denn
es gibt ja unterstützung aus
nato-ländern welche möglichkeiten gibt
es seitens der nato speziell die ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen
ich habe es ja eben schon gesagt die
nato ist nicht in der lage die ukraine
zu unterstützen weil alles was sie täten
und eine beteiligung an diesen krieg
gleich käme zu einem krieg zwischen der
nato und russland führen würde und das
hätte unabsehbare folgen nicht nur für
die ukraine wo er dann zunächst mal die
kampfhandlungen doch intensiviert würden
sondern für europa insgesamt
nun hieß es zu wochenanfang sagen der
vereinten nationen die aussicht auf
einen nuklearen konflikt einst und
denkbar sei nun wieder im bereich des
möglichen was bedeutet das genau
nun wir haben hier gehört von präsident
putin er zweimal damit gedroht
einmal nuklear waffen einzusetzen für
den fall dass er sich bedroht fühlt vom
westen wie er es formuliert hat und ein
zweites mal hat er die nuklearen kräfte
der russlands in eine höhere
alarmbereitschaft versetzt alles das
sind maßnahmen die natürlich ängste
auslösen die befürchtungen auslösen auf
unserer seite aber auf der anderen seite
haben wir auch gesehen dass beide
nuklearen supermächte die vereinigten
staaten und russland sich darum bemühen
eine
situation zu vermeiden in der es durch
ein technisches oder menschliches
versagen vielleicht auch durch eine
fehleinschätzung der lage zu einem
konflikt käme zwischen der nato und
russland der dann auch in ein nuklearer
konflikt münden könnte also das was man
als heißen bad bezeichnet das ist
reaktiviert worden man hat das überprüft
und damit ist die möglichkeit gegeben
auch missverständnisse zu vermeiden
ich habe ich glaube nicht dass jemand
die absicht hat also weder russland noch
sonst irgendjemand nuklearwaffen auf
dieser in dieser in dieser zeit
einzusetzen wir haben eine ein overkill
sozusagen an nuklearwaffen auf dieser
welt zu viele nuklearmächte aber auf der
anderen seite ist das auch ein
stabilitätsfaktor wie wir in der
vergangenheit gesehen da man muss eben
nur vorkehrungen treffen dass es nicht
zu einem missverständnis kommt der etwas
auslöst was eigentlich niemand will
eine art eine art missverständnis
könnten ja übertritte in nato luftraum
seien es gab sie in schweden vor tagen
es gab einen angriff auf eine auch von
der nato mit unterstützte oder genutzte
basis wenige dutzend kilometer entfernt
von der ukrainisch polnischen grenze
wenn so etwas passiert
nennen wir es entweder zwischenfall oder
provokation unbeabsichtigt beabsichtigt
sind dann die mechanismen die innerhalb
der nato greifen wenn so etwas passiert
zwei beispiele genannt die völlig
unterschiedlicher natur sind dass
flugzeuge in den luftraum also russische
flugzeuge in den nato luftraum
eindringen versehentlich oder mit
absicht das gibt es häufiger das hat
auch in der vergangenheit gegeben und da
gibt es eingespielte verfahren die dafür
sorgen dass kein zwischenfall passiert
ich spiele jetzt im einzelnen nicht
darüber sprechen aber diese verfahren
sind
international anerkannt und die sind
auch werden auch von den piloten
eingeübt etwas anderes ist ist der
zweite fall den sie geschildert haben
dass nämlich ein ausbildungszentrum in
der ukraine angegriffen wurde und in
diesem ausbildungszentrum haben vor dem
krieg offensichtlich ja auch nahe
angehörige der nato geübt zusammen mit
ukrainischen kräften es hat
offensichtlich auch manöver gegeben und
ausbildungsarbeit das ist eine völlig
andere situation denn dieses
ausbildungszentrum befindet sich auf
ukrainischem boden und auf ukrainischem
boden findet krieg statt
wir hören nun gehören nun dass eine
neutralität der ukraine ins spiel
gebracht wurde
was meint man in russland damit und was
würde eine neutralität wie auch immer
sie gemeint ist verändern
nun ich habe ja schon vor wochen gesagt
dass die frage welchen platz die ukraine
in zukunft in einer europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur einnehmen soll
ein türöffner ist für weitere
verhandlungen für weitere konstruktive
verhandlungen
russland will verhindern dass die
ukraine mitglied der nato wird russland
will auch verhindern dass auf dem
territorium der ukraine nato truppen
stationiert werden die die russland als
eine bedrohung ansieht oder eine
veränderung des gleichgewichts auch das
ist die russische sicht der dinge es ist
wenn man genau in den washingtoner
vertrag also in den nato vertrag hinein
schaut dann sieht man das in artikel 10
voraussetzung für eine
nato-mitgliedschaft genannt werden die
von der ukraine nicht erfüllt werden das
heißt also in diesem punkt besteht eine
kompromiss möglich kite und ich zitiere
jetzt einfach mal das was henry
kissinger schon 2014 gesagt hat er hat
gesagt wenn die ukraine wirklich eine
positive zukunft haben soll wenn sie
gedeihen soll und in sicherheit
existieren soll dann darf sie nicht zu
einem vorposten russlands gegenüber dem
westen werden aber sie darf auch nicht
zu einem vorposten des westens gegen
russland werden sie soll eine brücke
zwischen ost und west sein und das
bedeutet dass sie den status einer
konsolidierten
neutralität erhalten soll diese dieser
punkt ist offensichtlich teil auch jetzt
der gespräche zwischen der ukraine und
russland und offensichtlich sind beide
seiten bereit in diesem punkt ein
kompromiss zu erzielen
wie der im detail dann aussieht das ist
eine andere frage denn natürlich
verlangt die ukraine
sicherheitsgarantien für den fall einer
neutralität aber ich denke dass es
durchaus möglich da gibt es eine reihe
von möglichkeiten wie man das sicher
stellen können wenn diese frage geklärt
wird wovon und danach sieht es ja im
augenblick aus dann ergibt es ergeben
sich auch möglichkeit über andere
probleme zu diskutieren miteinander zu
reden und auch den weg frei zu machen
für eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur die für
stabilität und frieden in europa in
zukunft sorgen
er hat auch eine brücke die die ukraine
darstellen sollte mustern halten ich
danke ihnen sehr für ihre zeit und auch
für das interview vielen dank herr kujat